celebrate your little wise as an
entrepreneur a big believer in having
big wise and little wise your big why is
why you're doing this business right why
are you really doing this what's the big
impact you want to have on the world for
me I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs some big goal that
motivates you that forces you to stretch
and force you to get out of your comfort
zone and and become a better person a
better entrepreneur but i also like
having the little whys and the little
wise are their daily small wings that
you have in your business it's the
feedback from one customer that says
thank you so much you changed my life
and celebrating those is important
because that's the fuel because
sometimes that big why seems so big that
you say I can never hit that I can never
get there that's too far out what am I
thinking Who am I to be able to hit that
goal and the little wise keep you
motivated on a daily basis for me a lot
of my little wiser are you guys YouTube
comments you're leaving feedback below
you telling me I love that video it
gives me juice it makes me want to keep
going and do more of that and so I
wanted to celebrate a little why with
you guys today and the importance of of
my radio show I don't talk about it too
much on the channel so do radio show
every two weeks and I had a caller call
in two episodes ago who was a long
island DJ named Joey and he was a DJ he
was a singer he was a comedian he's a
performer and he wanted to incorporate
all of these things together and people
kept putting him in a box and saying you
are just a DJ we're hiring for a DJ
we're not interested in any other stuff
and he he asked me how do i how do I
stand out how do I bring these things
together and and follow my passion
because I don't want to just be a DJ and
so I gave him advice and he called in on
my next show to say thank you so much I
got my first customer because of that
he's he's making changes he's growing he
took a couple minutes on a radio show of
talking to him he changed his entire
business he has momentum now he has new
customers now he has
he hasn't he has a new life and that's
what fuels me so much every day and I
hope you have similar stores with your
business where you're really making an
impact on people's lives even if you
only touch them for a few minutes and
remind yourself of that and celebrate
those to keep you going and so I wanted
to share both clips the first call and
then the second thing you call and let's
roll them I've got Joey on the line Joey
where are you from and how can I help
from Long Island New York how you doing
ah well you just answered a lot of my
questions right there but when I
basically I am is I'm a professional DJ
comedian and the singer so what I was
trying to do was try to be different and
I wanted to package all my talents into
a go one man show type of thing I
started a website about a year ago and
I'm getting you know I'm surprised i'm
only getting maybe three or four gigs in
that direction and it a great party is
great to wear you know everything i'm
shooting for us is working out rates
just a matter of like you said targeting
finding out where i get those type of
clients you know Facebook in it and
Twitter in it and all that type of stuff
but I'm even thinking about me to get a
local commercial here on Long Island to
promote myself are you doing weddings or
corporate advisor who with your audience
well no weddings and stuff like that I
keep separate but what I'm doing
corporate events or if I'm doing up
birthday parties stuff like that more
entertainment the better you know so I'm
trying to take all my talents together
and put them into one party and it's a
great idea and it works great when it
happens and I really have to sell the
idea but it's not catching on you know
I've been doing it for about a year now
and like I said I like four or five
parties in the last year I get regular
parties now getting regular weddings and
sweet 16 and stuff like that but I'm
right come a lot of market this you know
I mean it's like people don't trust it
because new what's different so my trust
me it's good so yeah I think if you're
looking at social media your best bet is
going to be YouTube like I want to see
this because as you're driving it you're
saying well Jay comedian singer like I
I want to see your show I I have a UTI
have a website and i have videos on the
website but um I can't stay in traffic
into the website and you know it you
know I have business cards word of mouth
it's just uh I don't know people are
spending extra money a lot two histories
I can't figure out why something like
that one catch on I know I would want it
at my part yeah so the two things that
would look at is one so it's great to
have video i put a few more videos up
there beyond just one show and see if
you can have somebody I don't help
professional that first video is but
it's actually be doing corporate they
want to see professional so it might be
worth having helped to record one live
show that's done professionally because
it's a good reflection on your brand so
i would i would also see if I can get
some testimonials on video so those four
or five areas that you did can you go
back to some of the people in the
audience and say man that Joey is crazy
you made our event like the talk of the
town it was awesome you got to get him
on board just so that you said like its
new people are scared they are fearful
they don't want to make the company look
bad so having somebody come on and say
how great you were can add a lot of
value and reduce the risk for new people
coming on board right now it's the risk
it's the trust factor they'll trust it
it's like I tell about it down the warp
6 great a lot of fun and now we'll just
stick with the music like I you know
we're going to go I got to force some
somebody to change their they're so it's
put us right and it's great that it's a
medical like you really have a business
and this is an upsell for them but i
would get those two halves of the
renewal videos no I don't like I could
probably go back like you said go see
these people that I did the parties for
we're very happy it'd be no problem to
contact them some kind of testimonial
yeah I mean that's a huge risk reduction
because of course you're going to see
how great everything is right no no I'm
sure thing to say oh this is you know
I'm just I'm just trying to upsell you
and take your money you know but having
customers below about how great you were
as a lot of value and really reduces my
risk if I'm on the fence and I see a
great customer testimony or a couple of
them from like a company I might
recognize like I want to do it for those
guy
and I'm really happy okay let's try it
out the other thought I had was I would
start working with event organizers
event planners instead of trying to go
direct to the corporate because a lot of
the bigger corporate they don't do their
own stuff they hire event planners to
manage it for them and okay a good event
planner will have multiple clients so
instead of trying to sell one client at
a time if you get an event planner to
love what you're doing he or she can
sell you into tons of dates dozens of
hundreds of gigs because I that's their
job right so they could say okay well
here's a you know he can join team give
you the music but if you want something
extra special you know here's the video
when he's definitely with the back it up
maybe you should consider this complete
package right right right yeah that's
what my goal is like always to be
different to do something I try to get
yo soy entire I make a list of all those
people who are event planners in the
area you get way better returns out of
that and taking out a commercial on a
related station okay and also branded
something like call it something that i
will remember you know right like i
don't know what you're going to call but
something that gets memorable that
that's that sticks in my head is
something extra special right right Joey
good luck okay thank you thank you I
want to get to the calls i have joey on
the line Joey where are you from and how
can I help hey hey dude up from Long
Island New York no I spoke with you a
while back about I get more business you
know what the DJ deuce is no to yeah I a
DJ comedian singer yes yes yes so a lot
of to follow up with you and but I
really did was I updated the website and
I pushed it on on social media yeah and
I got I got the word out there and I
really got motivated after our
conversation and I did book a couple of
jobs like folks about two jobs and from
those jobs just by doing those jobs I
gave out cards and I have people
interested for future so just had to
take a step forward and just really you
know i think i was lazy with you know
with the website i think that's a huge
you know the Internet is huge and I will
awesome do you have the video up to no I
have a bunch of video footage actually
just yesterday I made a YouTube page
we're gonna put the videos of all that
stuff um it's just going to be for
business owners not every and you know
anything about business on that page and
I want to post that on social media as
well okay so let me let me kind of
reject my memory and also remind our
listeners you were doing DJ gigs but you
also had the comedy and singing show
that you wanted to introduce but you
couldn't get the corporations to say
yeah we want that which attorney for the
DJ business all right right right all
right all right Joey you texted my
memory yeah there's not safe it's they
will be in stage with an episode before
the nose talking about a plane it's safe
to follow the bj and I was trying to
push you know all my talents into one in
two wars royal parties I guess they'll
be disabled to get there to get more
work yeah and you know what corporations
are safe right like nobody wants to hire
the wrong guy and that makes that person
look foolish and they get fired over
right there they are safe birds exactly
Hey yes I'm doing it combat that you
reduce the risk by showing them what
they're going to get right like you
could talk about it as much as you can
see the blue in the face but it's all
friend it's going to fall on deaf ears
and it's greatly had some success so far
with the web the next step really is
like show me show me what I'm going to
get right make that video maybe your
next gig you can do it or just do your
own thing and get your friends to
filming put it all to god hath you can
stay here well looks like i have been
videotaping i have been been using my
iphone which is HD it's pretty clear let
me believe it yeah it's better than
nothing and you know I've been putting
them all into a folder on my desktop and
now I just want to cut them down edit
them down just to the good parts you
know just to the you know to get me
rolling all the garbage that's on it and
edit it down to like a two or three
minute video and then I'll going to push
that on the website as well as the
social media but yeah just taking
advantage of you know the internet it's
one thing I
was lacking I was doing a lot of
word-of-mouth people call me explaining
it over the phone it's so much easier to
tell people over my website and you know
I'm grass to you on having the courage
to take your iPhone and do it there's a
lot of entrepreneurs if you like all the
camera I don't know anybody has a camera
and they just procrastinating
procrastinating procrastinating you can
get started with an iphone you can meet
you it enough video off an iphone to
show what you're all about I'll tell you
the truth the quality is the quality
it's really good I mean it really is the
quality of an iphone this data is not
bad at all and it's like my item I was
telling me it's better than nothing then
knows better than not having anything no
you don't have to go all out and get the
best there you go in the middle
sometimes yeah I mean and then maybe
that leads to more gig and not lead to
be able to charge more that leads to
being able to invest in better gear and
equipment you start with what you have
when you have it and you continue to
build my thank you to you is motivating
me with with the internet and with
social media is that that definitely
opened up a lot of doors today and now
I'm more confident now that this is
going to work off the man I love it so I
appreciate the last phone call we had
because before that I feel like I was
just how i was thinking everything but I
wasn't doing it you know you could think
it out and think it out for you know
months and but the thing is to get your
foot down and just do it you know follow
through with you you know so and I did I
did I did after the last honk whatever
actually sort of tape and every gig goes
out after that have a nice folder full
of video and I'm gonna get to work on
that as well I love it you would drop
your website one more time for everybody
listening ok so the website now is super
DJ entertainment soon I DJ bring
entertainment dominum calm love it Joey
thank you so much for calling back in I
love hearing your program thank you so
much I appreciate everything all right
big area so thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe continue to
celebrate your little wise and if you
guys like this video you want to see
more just like it you can subscribe to
the channel thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon
make sure to check out my nose latter
yeah got 11 hi I'm Jason j-rod fonseka
of ra's online com and i want to say
Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring XD only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period